they're saying they're going to fire the
uh the execs the management I don't know
what would be the ethical thing to do
for this 10 12 13 million in stock that
they all sold
like they're the executives of the
company they lost a lot of people a lot
of money
I don't know I I'm I'm not 100 sure like
I don't know who actually is being
affected most mostly like who's really
being negatively affected
um I don't know I know that the the svb
was mostly crypto companies and and they
funded a lot of startups and stuff like
that so I don't know that there's a lot
of small investors that are small
Bankers you know small uh whatever you'd
call it uh at the uh that they that they
cater to so you know I don't know
exactly what what should be done and I I
don't even know that we should be making
decisions yet because it just happened
today